now a neo mast honest pickup artist has
bound to public pressure and canceled
the series of meetups for his followers
across Britain citing safety and privacy
concerns dire chalets ADIF known as
roofie sparked controversy with blog
posts about legalizing rape once it's
done on private property the 36 year old
American also encouraged men to date a
girl with an eating disorder here's some
more of what he said women are not at
all serving critical or important job
functions at a level above men and
society is better off with a not
participating full-time in the labor
force
he also said systems must be put in
place where a woman's behavior is
monitored and to decisions subject to
the approval of a male relative or
guardian who understands what's in her
best interests better than she does
herself
so should Britain ban him joining me now
to discuss that Ella Whelan a writer for
spiked online and Kate's mirth wait a
comedian and activist thank you both
very much joining us this morning Kate
Smith wait to you to and I mean what he
says it's rise level it's objectionable
but but should it be banned well what
we're talking we're not talking about
anybody being banned from saying
anything he said these things online if
this is the sort of thing you're
interested in hearing about or you want
to look at it and see why it's horrible
and disgusting you can go online and see
it we're asking the question is it in
the public interest for him to come to
Britain and hold meetings here and I
think it's quite obvious that it's not
and we've got a law that's already in
place that deals with a sort of game
progression rules and it says sorry Kate
but we have to be sure why shouldn't you
come and say it well but there have
always been restrictions on what you can
and can't say there's a big difference
to me which is very obvious between
expressing free speech and having your
opinion and actively advocating violence
which is exactly what his comments about
rape do and he's also said that if any
women attempt to attend these meetings
that he's trying to organize and that
they will be tracked down videoed
harassed hounded and I'll have their
lives made a complete misery I don't
think that that's that I accept
there's a big difference between making
threats and simply and expressing an
opinion it's quite clear to me that his
presence in this country is not in the
public interest and that's what the law
says it says we can just say no we use
that to this law pretty regularly to
turn that anybody with links to violent
organizations we did it recently with
Julien Blanc it was another guy from
this kind of what they call Mr a men's
rights activist and I say that in
complete inverted commas as a feminist I
consider myself a men's rights activist
I think we should have more paternity
leave and synchronized swimming in the
Olympics for for the guys I'm all over
that but this is not what these guys are
complaining about that they're actually
campaigning to do things like legalize
rape and I think that's absolutely
obviously shocking and unacceptable
okay Ella wheeler you don't think he
should be banned from the UK why no I
think we are talking about banning him
it's kind of a similar brought up Julian
blanket similar situation to Donald
Trump it's someone who shares views who
the majority of people in Britain would
not share he's kind of a crass
individual and most women would laugh at
him and most men would not listen to him
there's absolutely nothing interesting
about him and it wouldn't be in the
public interest to have him there but
that doesn't mean we should ban him we
should let him come say what he wants to
say and laugh at him or if you
particularly want to go to wherever
they're meeting up I know it's been
canceled now but if it hadn't you should
have gone to where they're meeting up
have your say as well have an argument
with him and show him up for the idiot
he is isn't that a fair point case those
but you should you should challenge
these people's for their opinions and
make them look foolish but he's actively
said that if we're an attempt to attend
these meetings you know that they're
going to be destroyed etc etc is this so
I don't think we're going to feel like
it is safe to go along and challenge
these views that's very much the point
isn't it policing that is that he's he's
actually threatening people and it's not
talking rape and sexual violence
seriously sorry Kate I know it's hard
being here because you're outside but
let let Ella come in i takes rape and
sexual violence very seriously and part
of that is that I don't see stupid
comments like a man like this as being a
serious threat to women words and
bizarre pickup lines cannot encourage
violence to women because they're just
stupid and the majority of us really
don't listen to them or laugh at them
and actually I know plenty of women
myself included who if somebody was
threatening me with violence would take
them on and I've seen Bruce Fein he's
hardly a frightening man I mean come on
now okay Katie does speak for offense
seriously so I find this a Miss arias
you're actually saying that it's alright
for somebody to read threatened with
violence because you would take them on
I mean I don't want to live in that kind
of world and I want to live in a world
where frightened with violence and it's
all very well for you to say that oh he
doesn't seem threatening to me he's not
that big a guy well you know maybe if
you were a smaller or less physically
strong woman an older woman someone more
physically linked a trailing wave after
you about you don't box Italy welcome
class women that she she's handled
ourselves now you're talking about
patronizing normalizing where you're
talking about people being vulnerable
and weak oh we're sick of you
patronizing us please back off let this
guy contour ignore it everybody has
society's having a right to be free from
threats of violence and that's not
happen today I want to freeze down face
things that we might agree societies say
okay the most important freedom is
freedom of speech okay - no it's okay
nobody is stopping him from saying
anything he wants to know what we're
saying and there's a regulation in place
that already says that the people who
are gonna get rid of that regulation
it's a free speech so okay Kate let's
say you're a second sorry can I just
change pause for a second I just want to
put a point to other words that you were
raising and get you're talking
separately swing here both of what
you're saying
hello some of the stuff that he says you
think you know that you can take it on
you can counter it but a lot of the
stuff that he's saying the message is
the underlying messages no means no
until it means yes what about these
messages being being sent to young
in the UK that they go along to an event
like this they think oh this might must
be alright because I'm here I'm in a
hall I'm listening to what this guy is
saying he's sending a message the wrong
message to young people in the UK is nee
and she should be stopped from sending
that message if the message he's sending
is absolutely gross and you know rape is
a crime and if we deal with it very
seriously I don't I think that he's a
completely disgusting individual we have
hang on we have plenty of people who say
things we disagree with his is
particularly quite a power I think it's
completely wrong and awful and dangerous
far more dangerous that what he's saying
is to say that young men would be
influenced by such a view by somebody I
just learned to obey Allah because
they're going eliza's and he's got a
million subscribers on the internet his
following is in comparison is very small
it's sad losers on the internet they
absolutely are insignificant and if they
ever tried it on with a woman they would
be slow Kanak because women are stronger
than that okay we've had a couple of
emails today we asked viewers what youth
what you would think about this what
your views are hang on a second case too
many miles that came in I must say that
there was a couple of women who said
that he should be banned but we had to
amp emails from men who I thought were
quite interesting one from Richard
Clifton who said it's surprising this
day and age that it's not surprise let
me have people like this around Western
society is so feminized now that men
have no real role they're second-class
citizens and divorce especially with
children with migrant problems etc with
anxiety against natural predispositions
and the hate feminism towards men is it
any wonder that a counter surge of
excessive masculine principles are going
to find a voice also Richard in Somerset
said basically he thought he should be
able to consider free speech okay do you
think there are some this is the case
sorry Kate do you not think that there
are men out there in society you feel
that there isn't a place for men young
men in society and he's speaking to them
I think that email that you've just read
out is incredibly offensive to men
actually when he says that we shouldn't
be surprised that an excessively
masculine culture comes out there well
if your definition of a really masculine
culture is one that wants to legalize
rape then I think we have to question
what on earth we're talking about
in terms of masculinity if there are
problems affecting young guys you know
issues around being able to talk about
mental health problems like I think any
feminist I know would say brilliant we
have to talk about these things it's so
important and it's so vital but if the
solution to that is to legalize rape
then I'm not entirely sure that that's a
solution that actually works for our
broader society what we have to be doing
is looking at what some public and it's
not like you know when I keep hearing
this thing about well you know we can
just laugh at it we can just make a joke
about it the fact is that rape is a very
serious crime it's not taken as
seriously as it should be in this
country I mean I've been a comedian for
like 12 years and I think it's an
important role in society but I don't
think that that is the answer to rape
and sexual violence I think the answer
is that we have to absolutely nip these
things in the part of a very simple way
of doing that at this point in Teresa
may needs to step up and do it okay I'm
gonna have to end down afraid we're out
of time but Ella you were nodding during
during Kate's response there so I know
that you at least agree with her on that
point
Ella we Lincoln spiked on line and
Kate's Mirth wait thank you both so much
for joining us keep your comments coming
into a serious guy news